vous avez fréquenté quand vous étiez pas
trop de canal des tas de gens que nous
allions à
une journée c'est les gens importants
que vous appelez des fois ils sont là
des fois ils sont pas là et quand il
s'empale à vouloir laisser un message
sur leur messagerie et on va faire une
interview messagerie
bonjour vous êtes sur la messagerie de
jean marie messier veuillez laisser un
message après le bip sonore c'est à vous
je te merde
bonjour
2 quelle carte il va donner non kardex
amis de jean marie messier beau jeu
l'adorent selon rambo
on va la garder que savez vous êtes sur
la messagerie d'andré rousselet veuillez
laisser un message après le bip sonore
c'est à vous je sais pas comment
jusqu'à la fin de mes jours je pourrais
vous remercier de nous avoir donné cette
liberté là bonjour vous êtes sur la
messagerie d'elvis presley pour laisser
un message après le bip sonore de tavaux
alors toujours morts
bonjour vous êtes sur la messagerie de
michel denisot pour laisser un message
c'est à vous on peut avoir du talent et
pas voir beaucoup de gueule
déjà
vous êtes sur la messagerie d'alain
chabat pour laisser un message c'est à
vous recevrai demain comme hier
bonjour vous êtes sur la messagerie de
michel le petit actionnaires ruinés par
vivendi universal
bah je suis content de voir que vous
vous refaites un peu hein et comme si on
met pas tout l'argent dans la fondation
de jean rené fourtou
bon jour sur les messageries de bertrand
méheut plus un message public sonore
c'est à vous merci de votre appel
monsieur pour me convier comme vous
l'avez fait à déjeuner avec vous avant
que vous déménagiez de l'immeuble de
canal je veux bien les jeunes avec vous
mais pas forcément dans l'immeuble a
moqué vidé bonjour vous êtes sur un
message l'idole un degré ou laisser un
message au public sonar c'est à vous
quand est-ce que tu remontes à paris
bonjour vous êtes sur messagerie de
steven spielberg y laisser un message
après la bip sonore c'est à vous
j'espère vous voir en juillet puisque le
jeu on s'est croisé à paris m'a dit
qu'il des tournées en juillet et que on
verra ce moment là bonjour c'est sur la
messagerie d'antoine de caunes pour
laisser un message après le bip sonore
c'est à vous quand tu reviens de
trouville arrête toi à paris bonjour
vous êtes sur la messagerie de patrick
le lay pour laisser un message après le
bip sonore c'est à vous
je me demande pourquoi j'ai fait votre
numéro
bonjour bien sur la messagerie de
stéphane bern l'islam est sage après le
bip sonore c'est à vous franchement
depuis le début de l'année je trouve que
tu te démerdes est pas trop mal un à
cannes c'est pas tout à fait ça 1 le
cinéma c'est pas trop son truc il faudra
forcément un truc qu'on sait bien faire
bonjour des sur des messageries madame
lescure
s'agit d'une heure et demie je suis là
d'accord sauf si on bouffe en sommeil
d'arbres mais bon dans trois heures et
demie demain matin 10 ans d'égarement il
a dit allez on dit de même un chalet à
lundi bonjour bonjour j'ai sur ma
messagerie de pierre lescure pour
laisser un message après le bip sonore
c'est à vous toujours mégalo mondiale et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais 1
pouces bleus